tell me about some of the
left eye music that was being recorded
because you know obviously you know she
she passed
you know
way before her time and and you know we
never really got to
get get treated to
left eye solo like i think we you know
we should have you know so how was how
was the music she was recording while
you were at def jam or death row well
left i was busting
excuse me
um so you know that's something that she
wanted to do for a mighty long time
right
excuse me would you show her skills
as an mc
you know with tlc
it was a different level of music
different genre of music
and lisa really wanted to be an emc she
wanted to show and broadcast her skills
as a rapper of skill as an emcee she's
from philly
so you know she wanted to let loose some
of that illadelph madness that she had
built up in her that she couldn't do
with tlc
in the face right or whatever company
they was with after the face so it was
like a
it was a outlet to release
this this entity in her she called nina
and so that was like her alias her alias
yeah what i'm saying
and she you know that's what she gave
her the lane for and she accepted it she
jumped on and
you know there's a whole different lisa
leftover was the music fire
she was fire yeah
i mean of course
i mean yeah you know what i'm saying
there's just there's all these like you
know albums we always heard about be
honest the music wasn't bad at all you
know it's just
different flow lisa
you know you'd be like oh wow visually
you'll be able to see where she was
going right you know what i'm saying if
you just hear it you'll be like
because you're so used to left eye
you probably wouldn't accept nina
unless you saw visually what she was
going for what she was going for and
then it'd be like okay because it's
still
left eye